now after a year plus of crushing
coveted mandates california governor
gavin newsom
will finally be fully reopening estate
next week
but as always there's a catch
one thing i'm certain of is there's
uncertainty in the future
the emergency remains in effect after
june 15.
what's the reason for that because we're
still in a state of emergency this
disease has not been extinguished
it's not vanished it's not taking the
summer months off
is that the wheel of fortune behind me
that's ridiculous
there's a word for government via
executive fiat it's called a
dictatorship
joining us now newt gingrich former
speaker of the house fox news
contributor newt
they don't want to let go of these
states of emergency that
they just declare by executive order
because it gives them all sorts of power
they can exert
when they feel it's appropriate what are
the dangers here
well look this is enormously dangerous
and i suspect
it's going to start leading to a whole
series of lawsuits because
you have governors who are clearly
violating the u.s constitution
the constitution was written to
guarantee our rights
against the government and now you have
governments out here
whether it's on blocking churches from
having sessions
or whether it's dictating to people or
saying which businesses can open up
or which schools can open up uh and and
i agree with your analysis the
there's something about being a liberal
democrat that just
loves power and it's an addiction
and they love being in charge and they
love frankly corruption
and so they use their power to reward
their friends
and punish their enemies and to take
care of their family
and to take care of their political
supporters and i think this is the
largest breakdown of the us constitution
in the nation's history of not counting
the civil war
but i just think in a non-civil war
environment
it's astonishing in places like new york
or michigan or illinois or california
how much power these governors have
grabbed
and you're exactly right it makes them
the equivalent
of a third world dictator and it
guarantees
massive levels of corruption now
a new if you have the chance to live in
like let's say you live in oakland
california nothing against oakland
but given what's happened to california
most beautiful state
i think in the whole country being
wrecked day by day
but if you have a chance to live in
oakland or live in nashville
why'd you stay in oakland l.a versus
miami or i mean again they're just
driving people
out of these states they're hollowing
them out yeah
i think california this last year lost 9
billion dollars
in tax revenues as people just left
i think some of the most famous people
in california are now in florida or
texas
i think you're seeing people move to you
to utah to idaho
to arizona in fact arizonans are worried
that if too many texas
californians show up they're going to
try to change the state into a blue
state
you know so uh but but the other thing
is deeper and sicker
and and you see it in the bye
demonstration there's an entire
generation
of left-wing democrats who have total
contempt for the rule of law
total contempt for the constitution and
who believe that is their
god-given right to override the
constitution
and to tell you how to live your life
and if you don't listen to them
to use the power of government to punish
you and this is
an extraordinary dangerous assault newt
i was
i knew you were coming on and i couldn't
wait to ask you about the
freak out over the american flag like
the left doesn't
they don't want to see the flag that's
why they were happy when the athletes
are always
kneeling and for the flag or they don't
like standing for the anthem
sunny hostin on the view today i know
you watch her every day let's
let's see it when i
drive into a neighborhood and it's not
july 4th and i'm not in a predominantly
military household neighborhood and
there are flags
american flags everywhere alongside
trump flags alongside flags in
stars in a circle i feel threatened
because the message is
very clear it's a message of white
supremacy
newt they're basically admitting what
we've we've thought about them all along
at least they're being out and open
about it
look what she just said it's first of
all anti-american
anti-patriotic and in a sense racist
i mean the person flying that flag could
be an african-american who served in the
marine corps
it could just be a person of latino
background
who loves america this idea that
automatically
red white and blue is bad i have to tell
you
i i disagree deeply bitterly with the
bible administration's decision
that american embassies uh can fly both
the the
both the black lives matter flag and the
gay pride frag
the american embassy should fly the
american flag
and only the american flag and the
congress ought to pass there's a bill in
called the old glory flag of the old
glory bill
which is very clear the only flag we
should fly
at an american embassy is an american
flag
newt thank you great to see you tonight
as always hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else